[Music]
russia's invasion of ukraine has
triggered a huge outcry across the world
many countries have introduced punitive
sanctions against russia in an effort to
put a stop to the war
german chancellor olaf schultz made it
clear that more sanctions could follow
let's not kid ourselves putin will not
change his course overnight
but very soon the russian leadership
will feel the high price it is paying
already in the last week the russian
stock market sank by more than 30
percent
that shows our sanctions are working and
we reserve the right to impose further
sanctions
the eu the us britain and canada quickly
introduced sanctions against russia
russian banks are now excluded from the
swift payment system leading banks have
been shut out of western capital markets
russian treasury bonds and bonds of some
companies can no longer be traded
that makes it difficult for the kremlin
to refinance its debt
the west has frozen 85 billion dollars
worth of russian assets and introduced
travel bans more than 500 people have
been affected including vladimir putin
russia's access to computer chips
computers and other high-tech products
has been blocked
the latest sanctions sent the russian
ruble tumbling more than 30 percent and
the russian central bank more than
doubled its key interest rate to 20
percent
some of the country's banks are expected
to collapse
and analysts believe the sanctions will
[ __ ] the russian economy for years to
come
but the full effects could take months
or even years
[Music]
it's been a month since the winter
olympics opened in beijing with
fireworks
and chinese president xi jinping waved
proudly from the stands
abandoned by most international leaders
she only had one prominent guest
russia's vladimir putin who certainly
knew at the time that he would need some
support from his powerful neighbor
that's because russia depends on close
ties with china after the west distance
itself from moscow
russia might be optimistic
last year bilateral trade with china
jumped 36 percent to a record 147
billion dollars it's set to reach 250
billion dollars soon that's 40 more than
current trade volume between russia and
the eu
currently russia is china's second
biggest oil supplier providing over 15
percent of its imports
the country also covers five percent of
china's demand for natural gas
meanwhile trade and foodstuffs has been
growing fast in 2019 china allowed the
import of soybeans from russia
last year it added beef to the import
list and just last week wheat
china is also a huge buyer of timber
from russia's far east with imports
worth more than four billion dollars
last year
as for trade in the other direction
china sells machinery mobile phones cars
and consumer products to russia with
exports surging by a third last year
china is also russia's largest foreign
investor having issued at least 125
billion dollars worth of loans for
infrastructure projects that are largely
tied to china's belt and road initiative
russia counts on china as its new key
trade partner
but beijing might show some hesitance
wary of trouble with its western
partners should it run afoul of
sanctions
[Music]
the assembly lines are shut down in the
russian city of kaluga
volkswagen polos tiguans and skoda's
rapid
are no longer being produced following
russia's invasion of ukraine
normally 4 000 people would be working
at vw's facilities in kaluga and nizhny
novgorod
it's located
340 kilometers east of moscow
and it's where vw produces skoda branded
cars the volkswagen group has also
ceased all exports to russia last year
subsidiary porsche delivered 6 000 cars
to russia vw blames the current crisis
and uncertainty for the export stop the
move brings vw in line with other car
makers like bmw and mercedes-benz
leading u.s car makers general motors
and ford have also cut off exports to
russia
[Music]
since russia invaded ukraine oil prices
have been surging
leading industrial nations now want to
tap their oil reserves to mitigate the
situation for consumers and companies
the international energy agency wants to
release 60 million barrels of crude oil
reserves
that's about four percent of all
emergency reserves of one and a half
billion barrels
meanwhile western oil companies continue
to scale down their operations in russia
bp the biggest foreign investor in
russia said it's abandoning its 20 stake
in state oil company rosneft at a cost
of up to 25 billion dollars
also oil giant shell now says it's
ending its cooperation with gas prom in
key oil and gas projects italy's annie
is joining shell and bp
traditionally neutral switzerland will
adopt all the sanctions that the eu has
already imposed on russia over its
invasion of ukraine
switzerland has banned five oligarchs
close to russian president vladimir
putin from entering the country
sporting sanctions against russia have
led to a run on german team schalke
soccer jerseys in the city of gales and
kirschen
demand for sure to the club rose after
the second division team dropped russian
state-owned energy giant gazprom as its
main sponsor
the swedish furniture giant ikea is also
suspending its operations in russia and
belarus affecting nearly 15 000
employees 17 stores and three production
sites in response to the war in ukraine
ikea is one of the largest western
employers in russia
home rental company airbnb says it will
offer free temporary housing for up to a
hundred thousand refugees fleeing
ukraine
ceo brian chesky sent letters to leaders
of poland romania germany and hungary
offering help to house the refugees
more than a million ukrainians have
entered the eu
since the russian invasion
[Music]
the closure of russian airspace
following the invasion is set to cause
massive disruption to international air
cargo and traffic
cargo flights and passenger aircraft to
asia have to take different routes
lufthansa cargo says that flights from
central europe to japan korea and china
can take several hours longer and will
carry up to 20 percent less freight this
will make flights and freight more
expensive
shipping is also feeling the
consequences of the war
and the sanctions against russia
the world's largest container shipping
company maersk suspended nearly all
container deliveries to and from russia
there will be exceptions however for
foodstuffs medicine and humanitarian
goods
german manufacturers are worried about
bottlenecks especially in raw materials
and intermediate products and possible
price increases
german car makers have around 50
suppliers in manufacturing sites in
russia and ukraine
it's still too early to predict what
impact exactly the war will have
russia and ukraine are amongst the
largest exporters of wheat accounting
for about one third of global exports
but these exports are now at risk and
this is hitting poor countries in africa
and latin america in particular
they're dependent upon cheap imports
[Music]
the people of war-torn yemen are very
concerned about the situation in ukraine
yemen's wheat reserves are expected to
last only a few more months but many
like here in the capital sana worry
about rising flower prices
the russian war against ukraine will
affect the whole world and not just us
yemen will undoubtedly be affected
we're an importer of wheat and most of
our food supplies come from abroad
lebanon says it has wheat reserves for
just one more month
its largest silos were destroyed in a
massive explosion in beirut's harbor two
years ago the country depends on wheat
imports with nearly 60 percent coming
from ukraine the government is now
looking for alternative sources
we've reached out to a number of
countries including the us india canada
and europe that produce the soft wheat
that's needed for the air bread styles
we produce in lebanon
turkey depends on wheat imports from
russia the country is in the midst of an
economic crisis with runaway inflation
there have been massive protests over
rising food prices
when we talk about relations with russia
we usually think about weapons or energy
but much more significant is that turkey
is very dependent on the russian
agricultural sector especially for wheat
barley soybeans sunflowers and corn we
buy everything from russia even
chickpeas many turks fear the war will
make matters worse and continue to drive
up the prices of basic foodstuffs
the sanctions against russia and its
counter sanctions will affect many
european companies
eastern german enterprises like this
specialized machinery producer
kieselstein are among those that will be
hardest hit
the cabinet space company can process
steel copper and other wires
such a machine costs up to a million
euros each one is custom built for
buyers
the company is a global market leader
managing director jens kieselstein
doesn't know whether he can keep all 45
employees on payroll
some top customers are in russia
but the sanctions resulting from
russia's invasion complicate business
we're currently preparing a contract
worth several million euros over the
next two years
if the contract cannot be fulfilled
according to the current terms
we will of course need or have to look
for alternative customers
that will take time
it could lead to a cut in working hours
and in the worst case scenario to
layoffs
the medium-sized company is not an
isolated case
in the eastern german city of chemnitz
formerly called makstat many companies
have long-standing business ties with
russia
christophe neueberg a foreign trade
expert at the region's chamber of
industry and commerce believes that
hundreds of millions of euros in sales
have already been lost here due to the
sanctions following russia's annexation
of crimea in 2014.
today putin's war could bring trade with
many former soviet republics such as
georgia to a standstill
because russia actually has a central
distribution function
many companies have established a
subsidiary in moscow or in other russian
regions
especially in the metals processing
sector
and from there they were active in the
surrounding regions
yen
does not believe that the latest
sanctions will really hurt russia
at least not as far as trade is
concerned
we have asian competitors there who then
just bridge a gap in the market
and that would lead to cuts in our
business here
so others
that only the complete exclusion of
russia from international payment
systems can really put pressure on the
autocrat vladimir putin